today on the mat well show an article in
The New York Times now claims that
feminists never said believe all women
don't believe you're lying ears they
didn't say that they never said it they
did they didn't say they haven't spent
the last five years saying that that was
all a devious right-wing trick a
conspiracy that's what the New York
Times is claiming and other other people
on the left are echoing that claim so
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the extraordinary
not to mention counterproductive and
stupid measures that some businesses and
people are putting into place ostensibly
to offer protection from the coronavirus
and in our daily cancellation the time
has finally come
finally to cancel the UN and it's a long
long past - I'll explain why I'm
canceling them all of that coming up but
first starting with this you know ie I
actually had a whole different plan for
this show today but then sort of at last
minute I happen to see this piece in the
New York Times and now I have to call an
audible because this thing pissed me off
so much that I have to rant and rave
about it right at the top here I don't
have a choice I have to so
the stage here you know our friends on
the Left have been trying very hard over
the past several weeks to reconcile
their treatment of Tara Reid who is the
Joe Biden Joe Biden sexual assault
accuser with their previous claims that
we should believe women or believe all
women only it's very hard to reconcile
because the believe women champions have
discovered one woman they won't believe
and it just so happens that she's the
woman accusing the Democratic candidate
for president what a coincidence you
know so it very much appears that these
people all are a bunch of vile gutless
shameless hypocrites that's how it seems
you know it really comes across that way
how can you go from shouting believe
women for years and years and years to
suddenly don't believe that hussy she's
lying through her teeth that's that's a
pretty tough transition to make and a
noticeable one a conspicuous one it's
going to make people think that you're
full of crap so how do you get around it
it's a it's a tough spot that people on
the Left are in now one way of getting
around it is to just not be a hypocrite
and not have a double standard and apply
the same standard to Tara Reid and Joe
Biden that you applied to everybody else
that's one thing you could do that's the
honest approach but if you're not going
to be honest then what are you gonna do
well feminists on the Left have figured
out what their strategy is going to be
they're going to do what they always do
which is lie and try to rewrite history
so much so that now they are actually
claiming that believe all women was
invented by the right wing they are
trying to right now as we speak they're
trying to rewrite the history books
while we watch them do it there does it
like right in front of us pulling the
history books out and ripping out pages
while claiming they're not doing that
hoping we'll forget everything they've
said and done for the past several years
which brings us to this New York Times
piece written by Susan Faludi
title believe all women is a right wing
trap how feminists got stuck answering
for a canard amazing that's yeah how did
they get stuck answering for the things
that they've said I don't know we'll
find out here's what the article says in
part it says Joe Biden has been accused
of sexual assault and conservatives are
having a field day exultant that they've
caught feminists in a new hypocricy trap
a woman with no corroboration beyond
contemporaneous accounts charges a
powerful man with a decades-old crime
hmm
doesn't that sound mighty close to
Christine Blasi Ford's complain about
against Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh yes yet this time many
liberals who've championed the me2
movement seem skeptical gotcha yes
gotcha that's right that's I mean we
weren't its we weren't looking for the
gotcha but you have presented it to us
and yes this is a this is a gotcha
moment that you have created for
yourself but not so fast because here
comes the reversal move from Susan she
says in fact believe all women does have
an asterisk it's never been feminist
boilerplate what we are witnessing is
another instance of the right to crying
what it imagines the American women's
movement to be spend some mind-numbing
hours tracking the origins of believe
all women on social media sites and news
databases as I did and you'll discover
how language like a virus can mutate
overnight
all of a sudden yesterday's quotes
suffer the insertion of some foreign DNA
that makes them easy to weaponize in
this case in this case the foreign
intrusion is a word is a single word all
in my online searches I encountered some
feminists who seemed genuinely to
subscribe to the phrase but
overwhelmingly the Twitterati deploying
the phrase where conservatives wielding
it as a whip why because the write knows
that me too activists do well what
because the write knows what me to
activists do well to keep in mind peril
lies in purity if the pluralism of the
women's movement can be reduced to rigid
boilerplate in the public mind then the
future of me too will have more to
from a single untruthful woman whom its
sworn to defend them from boatloads of
predatory men this is why I believe all
women is not an amplification of
believed women but its negation
and so on and so forth so where does
this leave feminist feminism has indeed
believed many things about all women
that all women are deserving of equal
treatment under the law
equal pay in the workplace reproductive
health freedom from domestic violence
and feminists have long held that all
women should be believed when the all
refers to all categories of women ie
equal regardless of race religion or
economic status this is what Anita Hill
meant when she said in a CNN Town Hall
in 2017
until we can believe all women every
woman's voice has value none of us
really will be seen as equal and good
luck finding any feminist who thinks we
should believe everything all women say
even what they say about sexual assault
ok so there you basically have the claim
you know and you have to sift it's a lot
longer than what I just spent too too
long reading but you have to sift
through a lot of diversion tactics and
obfuscation and everything to get to
what she's trying to claim the claim
being made here incredibly and it's a
claim that has been repeated and
amplified by many other left-wing
feminists and others on the left is that
they never said believe all women they
said believe women and you see those are
two completely different things so we'll
talk more about this in just a second
but first I want to check in with Roc
Auto calm you know when you go into an
auto parts store the problem is on top
of audio all the other issues you have
now going into stores in general in
these days they're not guaranteed to
have what you want even if you call I've
had experience where I call ahead and
they say they have the part you come in
they don't have it there was a
miscommunication rockauto.com is so much
easier than walking into a store and
having to answer all the questions and
you know finding out what they have the
very limited assortment of things that
they have rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear much like airlines do why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts that's the question there's no
reason rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices want to
emphasize that rockauto.com are reliably
low and you know I'm telling you this
all the time if you don't believe me
just call my bluff go check it out
rockauto.com
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
okay so it's not believe all women it's
believe women that's that's the basic
thing jill jill philipovich is a
prominent feminist writer she shared
this article on twitter approvingly of
course and summarized the point this way
she says this from Susan Faludi is so
important feminists never said believe
all women the right inserted the all
feminists said believe women that is
start with the assumption that women are
telling the truth instead of reflexively
doubting them ok let's just be very
clear about a couple of things here
number one there is no difference at all
between believe women and believe all
women if you said believe women then you
said to believe all women it's the same
thing the all is implied when you say
believe women you are saying believe
almond if people on the right were
inclined to use the phrase believe all
women it was only to emphasize to
highlight the danger and absurdity and
stupidity of the slogan that feminists
came up with believe women is believe
all women no difference not at all you
know it'd be like if I said if I said I
love dogs which I don't but let's just
say I did that and then you came by with
your German Shepherd and said hey check
out Rex and I said you I hate that thing
get it away from me now you would be
quite reasonable to respond by saying
hey you just said you love dogs and it
would be
use for me to say yeah but I never said
I love all dogs because loving dogs
means loving all things that are dogs
that's what it means if there are dogs
you don't love then you don't love dogs
you love certain dogs and not others so
if if what you meant was I love certain
dogs then you should have said that
then saying I love dogs now the
statement I love dogs is true even if
you actually hate certain dogs it's true
technically that you know you do love
dogs but the all is implied in the
statement I love dogs so if you actually
have a deep-seated hatred for certain
dogs then for the sake of clarity in
proper communication you would need to
say something like I love certain dogs
or I love some dogs or I love most dogs
or even I love all dogs but one any of
those would work and and be watch be
much clearer and much truer but you need
some kind of qualifier if you just say
it as a blanket statement then you've
made a blanket statement
what feminists are now claiming is that
the all was not implied and believe
women actually some was implied that's
what that's what they're telling us now
is that is that they really meant
believe some women and we were supposed
to understand that that was the
implication
but that's nonsense of course in fact if
they only ever meant that we should
believe some women then the slogan was
totally unnecessary the the whole
movement was unnecessary
yes of course we should believe some
women nobody ever claimed otherwise
there's there's been nobody anywhere
saying that we should believe no women
that was that was never a position
anyone took nobody ever said that we we
can't believe women ever about anything
what some of us did say is that women
should be believed under certain
circumstances if there's good evidence
if there's a good reason if she's
credible if the accusation is credible
so on and so forth
that was C that was the approach that a
lot of us were taking believed women was
a slogan invented in contrast to that
approach it was literally invented as a
response to a retort to the believe some
women philosophy now they're trying to
pretend that it was actually meant to
support the philosophy that these
feminists have spent years railing
against again I'm amazing
just totally shameless oh and by the way
for the record these people actually did
say all so it wasn't just that they all
was implied they actually said it
themselves so I you know I have evidence
I mean and any of us can go online in
Google and you can go back and you could
look at the rallies you could see the
signs that we're holding you could you
know you could see the tweets and the
things that they said you know on cable
news and everything but here's just one
example take a look at this that was
this is during the Cavanaugh hearings we
believe all all all survivors we believe
all survivors and before you try to say
oh it says survivors not women yes well
the point is what what are you believing
about the survivors you're believing
that they are survivors right to say we
believe all survivors is to say we
believe everyone who claims to be a
survivor of sexual assault everyone all
all of them that is a huge sign that
they are holding at the Capitol hearings
and that many people are gathered around
approvingly endorsing that message all
now it's yes there's there's no way to
actually live by that that is an
impossible standard that you couldn't
actually believe and live by true
then just say that I mean come out and
just say that you know yes I mean we did
say this and that was our but but but
clearly it's crazy and we and you know
we didn't really mean it
we shouldn't have said it okay there
needed to be a lot more nuance in this
conversation and we were wrong with you
could just say that
number two jill philipovich
you know tried to make believe women
seem more reasonable by explaining that
what she really meant is that you know
we should start what woman she said
should we should start with the
assumption that women are telling the
truth which which by the way is exactly
what Biden said almost verbatim during
Kavanagh he said that we should
something like we should start with the
assumption that the essence of what a
woman is saying is true when she makes a
an accusation yes well that is certainly
what believed women or believe all women
would entail but but do you not see that
spelling it out like that actually makes
it sound even worse that doesn't that's
not a clarification that makes it sound
better or more reasonable okay no you
can't start with the assumption that
what she's saying is true of course you
can't
our entire philosophy and system of
justice is built on the idea that you
start with the assumption presumption of
innocence of the accused yes now you
aren't required to do that outside of
the context of a courtroom but it's also
again not just the system of justice is
our philosophy our idea of justice is
that the most just thing to do the most
just way to approach it is to start with
a presumption of innocence when an
accusation is made that's your starting
point and what that means is because
there's a difference right if you're
starting with the assumption of
innocence of the accused and what that
means is if the person making the
accusation whatever the accusation is
what we're saying to that person is show
me the goods okay come with some
evidence give me reason to believe
because I'm not just going to believe it
on your word we can't do that now if
we're
starting with the assumption that what
that the accusation is true which is
what even with Jill you know Flo povitch
right now is saying that that's that's
supposedly her her philosophy well if
you're starting with the assumption that
the accusation is true then what you're
saying to the accused is you better give
me reasons to believe you're innocent
you better come with evidence that
you're innocent
putting the accused in the impossible
position of having to prove their
innocence or the the nearly impossible
position if not impossible because
you're trying to prove a negative you're
trying to prove that you did not do
something which is almost impossible to
do especially when it was years ago
so you see what they're doing here this
is the definition of gas lighting
they're saying no we didn't say believe
all women we said believe women and then
no we didn't mean that you should
literally just believe everything a
woman says we meant that you should
start with the assumption that
everything she says is true these are
all just a series of distinctions
without differences these are all words
that mean the same thing it's like if I
said no I didn't say it was a square I
said it was a geometric object with four
equal straight sides and four right
angles same thing it's just a different
way of saying the exact same thing so
this is gaslighting number three and of
course you know the big problem here is
that whether it's believe all women or
believe women or assume that what women
say is true whichever dumb slogan you go
with which all mean the same thing the
problem is that the left did none of
those things with respect to terror read
okay Jill you're saying you know we just
have to assume that what the woman is
saying is true
that's all okay well are you assuming
that what Tara Reid said is true
did you start with that assumption no
they most certainly did not assume that
what Tara Reid is saying is true they
most certainly did not believe her
in fact from day one well actually from
day one from day one to about day 40
they just ignored her and then finally
when they were forced to acknowledge
their existence they set to work
immediately to discredit and destroy her
and you know what maybe they're right
about her
maybe she is a lying scumbag it's quite
possible it might even be probable some
of the stuff that's come out about Tara
Reid is is relatively damning so it's
it's possible she's making this up I
wouldn't shock me any
I've said all along that my immediate
reaction is to doubt anyone who comes
with an accusation years later and
during a you know a political campaign
or a Senate confirmation hearing you
know anyone who comes along decades
later when the accused person is you
know in the news for whatever reason a
prominent figure and now they decide to
come out and say oh by the way that
person raped me thirty years ago any
time someone does that any time my
immediate reaction is to doubt is to be
skeptical it's not to say that it's
definitely not true I'm not gonna rule
it out it's just I'm gonna have a lot of
skepticism that's my reaction and I'm
allowed to have that attitude because I
never said believe all women or believe
women I I've said all along that we
should believe a woman if there is good
reason to and if not then we shouldn't I
think the circumstances of this
accusation like like the circumstances
of Ford's accusation are already good
enough reason to be skeptical if a man
abuses you and you want to accuse him
publicly maybe do it sometime within 30
years you know like at a certain point I
don't think that's too much to expect
and if you're gonna do it don't wait
until a presidential campaign or a
Supreme Court nomination to come out and
say by the way I don't think it's too
much to expect yeah I mean if so if
you're abused or assaulted or something
by a man I you you have every right to
come out and you should come out and say
it
it's just don't wait thirty years you
know
but again I can take this approach
consistently because I've always said
this
it's the left people like Jill and the
writer of this Times piece and the rest
of them who have said many many many
many many times that waiting years to
accuse someone is not an indication that
a story is false that's what they've
said and that other examples of a woman
being untrustworthy or or you know
manipulative don't mean that that she's
lying about this particular thing and
they've said many many many times that
inconsistencies in a stories in a story
don't mean the story isn't true holes in
the story don't mean the story isn't
true an inability to remember details
you know they've said many times
especially about Christine Ford none of
that stuff matters it's not relevant
that's what they've said only now they
abandoned it wholesale and pretend like
they never said any of it because they
are again lying shameless vile
hypocrites and you know the fourth thing
you know just you find again feminists
so desperate to be victims that now
there's they're basically claiming to be
victims of themselves you know what was
the subhead of this article it said how
feminists got stuck answering for a
canard
yeah they got stuck answering for a
canard they came up with that's what
happens with canards if you come up with
a canard you got an answer for it
in other words you're answering for your
own words the standards that you set and
so feminists set these standards and now
we're turning around and saying what
about your standards and they're saying
out there you stop it I'm victimized
they become fainting dam damsels in
distress the moment they you know the
moment anyone asks them to be consistent
it's pathetic
all right let's move on I said I had to
ran rave so there was my ran right let's
go to news headlines number one as we
emerge back into society and out of
hibernation some companies and some
people are going to rather ridiculous
lengths I think in an attempt to protect
themselves from the virus and I'm all
about you know I I I don't hold it
against anybody for taking precautions
and being careful that's great but it
there has to be a limit so I mentioned
this on Friday here's a cafe that this
is in Germany actually a cafe that
requires diners to wear pool noodles on
their head for social distancing so you
take a look at the picture that's what I
mean you've got you've got grown adults
sitting at a cafe with pool noodles
hanging off their head and the idea is
it's you know that's going to give you
the social distancing because if your
pool noodle comes within you know it
touches another person then you know
that you're too close or how about
you're an adult okay you're not a child
and so just don't come within six feet
of another person you should be able to
handle that you don't need a pool noodle
on your head and then here's a bar in
Maryland that that has but here's the
the image of it as a bar in Maryland has
customers in these big inner tube things
on wheels and this is supposed to
enforce social distancing now that looks
like a bar I don't know it doesn't say
what bar it is what it looks like a bar
in Ocean City Maryland and I've been to
Ocean City many times i guarante is what
I can tell you okay based on my
experiences within that environment I
guarantee you all of those things there
will be destroyed in a week from drunk
people playing bumper cars in them
guaranteed I I give that one week before
all of those things are destroyed I
think about 75 percent will be destroyed
from bumper cars then you're gonna have
about 25 percent that are go missing
because drunk people steal them and then
jump into the ocean with them that's
what's gonna happen I'm just I'm trying
to imagine myself at 22 in Ocean City
Friday night go to a bar and they
give you one of those I would have loved
it
for the reasons that the bar intends in
fact I still would love it right now
today as a as a grown man with four kids
if you gave me one of those I would be
running around doing bumper cars that's
what I would do and then and then here's
this this is just the saddest thing I've
maybe ever seen
take a look at this report from CNN
excitement builds but her
great-grandchildren never saw Nana quite
like this put your arms through the
slots after two months of no hugs 85
year old Rose Gagnon finally got to wrap
her arms around her kitties I wanted to
cry because I couldn't believe that this
was happening and the kids too
so Rosa's adult granddaughter Carley
Marinero of Rockford Illinois got to
work how can I do this not putting bags
over my kid or her for under 50 bucks
she built some time using PVC piping
plastic and tape this is a good hug oh
yeah yes because having a bunch of
people press their faces up against
plastic having a bunch of people in
succession press their face up against
plastic that's a lot more sanitary and
healthy right I can tell you this if I
made a contraption like that so that my
parents could hug their grandkids they
would look at me like I'm a lunatic and
then they would walk right around it and
hug their grandkids like normal human
beings so not only are these measures
pointless and counterproductive and less
safe and less healthy but they also are
you know what they're undignified halves
dignity it's never okay to lose your
dignity no virus can excuse you of your
dignity a man a grown man does not wear
a pool noodle on his head
III think I could say that or walk
around in a big inner tube like a
toddler and a fisher-price Walker
and I can't imagine that any grandparent
wants to wrap themselves in saran wrap
before hugging their grandchildren it's
just it's it's actually not worth it if
you told me that the only way for me to
avoid coronavirus is to you know is to
wrap myself in saran wrap like that
thing or walk around in the in the in
the toddler walker thing I would say you
know I'd rather have coronavirus
honestly I don't want coronavirus but if
if this is the only way to avoid it I'll
just take the virus thank you because I
want to have my dignity and I'm and you
know that's that's also important to me
as a human being number two this got a
lot of attention yesterday watch this
what's your reaction to the president
saying that he is now taking
hydroxychloroquine are you concerned
well first let me say how happy I am
about your new baby
how lovely Oh Wyatt Wyatt how perfectly
names we all know why that is and
congratulations and as you as you know
our Father you see how important it is
to keep the world safe for the children
for the children as far as the president
is concerned the our police our
president and I would rather he not be
taking something that has not been
approved by the scientists especially in
his age group and in his shall we say
weight group had but it is morbidly
obese they say
so I I think it was it's not a good idea
I'm sorry unpopular opinion here
probably unpopular at least on the right
I find that hilarious
just do the the morbid obesity comment
the delivery great stuff from Pelosi and
I don't say that often in fact that's
probably the first time in last time
that I have ever said or will ever say
that but some folks on the right have
been upset about this they you know
getting offended on Trump's behalf and
everything but you know you can't do
that guys you just can't Trump Trump
insults everyone always all the time
he's the king of insults he just insults
everybody it's it's practically the
reason he was elected so he can take it
if you dish it you're gonna have to take
it you can't sit there and cackle every
time Trump insult someone and then go
why I never whenever someone dishes it
back to him you just you can't do that
you really can't now I know the claim
from people on the right is that this is
a double standard because Pelosi is
body-shaming the president and I thought
we're supposed to celebrate obese people
and and and and tell you know say fat is
beautiful so shouldn't she be saying
that Donald Trump is a is a big fat
glorious beautiful man shouldn't
shouldn't isn't shouldn't that be what
she's saying that's the claim from the
right right now I get that it is a
double standard yeah I totally agree
fine but there's also when it comes to
Trump clearly let's be honest with each
other there are a number of rather
glaring double standards when it comes
to how we approach Trump and one of them
is this that he the guy just says
whatever he wants to anybody and if he
ever gets it back if anyone ever insults
him back then he along with people on
the right will you know they build up
they'll claim they're not offended but
they are definitely acting offended how
dare you say that about the press about
our president don't say that about my
president they go into that whole
routine just stop just just just
everyone just stop this is what
political discourse has become in
America it's two groups of people with
glaring double standards accusing each
other of having glaring double standards
and
I just get tired okay number three I'll
give you just the headline here this is
from CBS News it says some grocery
workers scared to death to return to
work and I tell you about that headline
because we're gonna see a lot of
headlines like this we already have
we're gonna see more the media in its
last-ditch effort to keep everything
closed down and here's my response to
that as I've been saying you know all
along that if if a grocery worker is
scared to death to return I don't think
there is any reason to be scared to
death in fact this is one of the rather
conspicuous elements of the whole
situation that we've got these quote
unquote essential workers like at
grocery stores and Walmart and Target
everything that have been working this
whole time not just working but have
been dealing with hordes and crowds of
people every day all day and only
recently started wearing masks most of
them and yet there has not been a you
know manat seen grocery store workers
and quote unquote essential workers
dropping like flies left and right
it hasn't been a bloodbath of essential
workers dying from the virus from being
exposed to it thank God but based on the
way this was portrayed that's what you
would have expected and it hasn't
happened which i think tells us
something and it also tells us that if
you're you know if you work at a grocery
store there's probably nothing to be
worrying about
that's what recent history would tell us
but regardless you know if you're scared
to go to work then don't go I'm I I do
not believe that we should force anyone
I am not in favor of and I don't think
anyone else is I haven't heard anyone
suggest that we should send guys into
homes like send send cops into people's
homes to drag them out and drag them the
door I'm not in favor of that it's a
free country you want to stay home you
can the only thing I would add though in
my opinion if you are a physically
capable person who is not in one of
these particularly vulnerable groups and
you choose not to go to work because
you're scared that's fine you have every
right but I don't think we should
continue to support you I don't think
you should get unemployment if you want
to choose to stay home we're not gonna
pay you to hang out on your couch and
watch Netflix it and I think that's
pretty reasonable number four let's do
something positive here the governor of
New Jersey this isn't the positive part
we'll get to that but the governor of
New Jersey is a lunatic and he's in fact
he said yesterday that he wants to keep
the state locked
he said we that the state will not
return to normal until there's a vaccine
that's what he said yesterday so
fortunately many of his residents many
residents of the state are ignoring him
as well they should and they're
continuing with their lives which is
good a gym in the state opened up
yesterday in violation of the governor's
dictates cops showed up you think you
know where this is gonna go but then it
takes a sudden right turn watch we are
here we plan for the worst hope for the
best and it seems like normally you are
all in violation of the executive order
well you hang out on that note have a
good day
[Applause]
beautiful see that makes me proud to be
an American that's and that's a good cop
right there that's a that's a man doing
his duty I think and we've seen this
from some cops even from the very
beginning which I which I'm very
impressed with but it also puts into
relief the you know the the police
officers who have been enforcing these
draconian laws and arresting people for
not social distancing or whatever not
wearing their masks right and the excuse
for that is they're just following
orders
well the excuse doesn't hold because you
see these other very good police
officers who are saying I'm not going to
enforce this I'm not that's that is an
order I'm not gonna follow I'm not gonna
round a bunch of people up and haul them
off to jail for going to the gym just
not gonna do it
so great great job from that police
officer fine five finally speaking of
embarrassing coronavirus things I forgot
I forgot to mention this one this is
another one right here a new invention
that allows you to wear a mask while
eating and you see there's a hole there
in the mask that opens up so you could
eat while wearing a mask so isn't this
kind of like making a bicycle helmet
that has a big a big huge hole in the
back of the head area in case you have
to scratch your head kind of defeats the
purpose of it just another I eat it when
you see when you see that kind of thing
if you're wearing a mask with a hole in
it then it really is just sort of about
virtuous signaling isn't it because the
mask is not doing a damn thing now I'm
not one of those people that says that
everyone out wearing a mask is virtuous
signaling they may be wearing a mask
because they have to if they want to go
to the store they may be wearing a mask
because they're in you know one of these
vulnerable groups you don't know you
know you don't know what their situation
is but this kind of thing yeah it's just
what's the point
all right let's move our bag we got
emails in a second that I want to have
time for so we'll do this quickly for
our daily cancellation we're gonna be
cancelling the United Nations many very
good reasons to cancel the UN this is
the one I'm choosing because it's the
one that popped up yesterday here's the
tweet from the UN it says what you say
matters hell
create a more equal world by using
gender-neutral language if you're unsure
about someone's gender or are referring
to a group and then we get the guide
here with the UN instructing us on how
we are to speak from now on it says if
you don't know someone's gender or when
talking about a group use gender-neutral
language and then it gives us the the
old barbaric primitive way of saying it
and then and then the new enlightened
way so mankind is crossed out instead we
say humankind
instead of Chairman we say chair instead
of congressman we say legislator said a
businessman we say representative
instead of policeman we say police
officer instead of landlord we say owner
and said a boyfriend or girlfriend we
say partner
instead of salesman we say salesperson
he said a man power we say work force
instead of maiden name we say family
name instead of fireman we say
firefighter instead of husband or wife
we say spouse okay I've got a different
idea for the UN here's here's my so
that's one idea
okay
my idea is why don't we just continue
saying whatever we want to say
and using normal words
and why don't we just not care at all
about the fragile feelings of anybody
stupid enough to be offended by it
because that's the thing if you're the
kind of person who would actually feel
in any way upset even if you don't say
it if there's any part of your brain
that hears the word mankind and feels a
little bit upset by that then your
feelings are irrelevant don't care I
really don't care I don't mean you
you're totally traumatized by it you
collapse into the fetal position on the
floor doesn't matter I have no sympathy
at all I'll just step right over you and
I'll laugh a laugh at you edge I will
laugh at you and step over you and keep
walking while saying exactly what I want
to say I think that is the right
approach and that's that's my suggestion
for the UN also by the way you idiots
human has the word man in it but we
can't say mankind because it has men how
about humankind so you put the Hugh in
front of it then it's okay and what
about person it has Sun in it / Sun
that's kind of masculine isn't it in
fact get this this is going to blow your
mind UN the word woman
as man in it wool man in fact look look
at this look at this this graphic from
the UN that we had up on the screen here
at the bottom it says UN women tag us
that's like the organization UN we men
men we're men you've got it in your own
name
well you better that's that's that's
pretty bad you better come up with a
different name for women you got to
rename them and what's the problem with
boyfriend or girlfriend that you're
you're speaking specifically about
somebody we partner i that this is this
is one now you could say whatever you
want doesn't offend me but it I always
cringe a little bit when people say
partner refer to their spouse or their
partner makes it sound like a business
transaction I mean it makes it sound
like you know it's like something says
it's like someone you're you you you
work on in a law or law firm worth or
something I know that's someone you're
romantically involved with but use
whatever words you want because that's
your affair not mine okay so the UN is
cancelled for that reason and for so
many others let's go finally to emails
and you can always email the show by
having access to the mailbag if you're a
daily wire member that's one of the
great perks
probably the greatest perk that you get
is you get to send me an email and we
will go to
let's see
Robbi says Matt says Matt I'm not going
to bother debating the trans issue with
you because I doubt there's anything
anyone can say to change your mind at
this point instead my question is why do
you care so much why can't you let
people live their lives isn't that what
you've been preaching with the shutdown
I generally agree with you on a lot but
I don't get your obsession with this
issue it doesn't hurt me if someone if
someone wants to say they're a woman or
whatever is it true Who am I to say but
I'll let them live their lives and I
think you should do the same okay hi
Robbie
so I have to tell you
I mean any offense to this but this is
one of the dumbest and most pointless
and boring responses a person can give
to any issue it's common to so don't get
me wrong you know you're not alone you
have a lot of dumb boring company in
saying this if that makes you feel
better why do I care so much well first
of all why do you care that I care so
much about that we could do this all day
why do you why do I care so much well
why do you care that I care then you can
ask why I care that you care that I care
and I can ask why you care that I care
that you care that I care and you can
say why do you care that I care that you
K they way we could go back et cetera
etc unto infinity or maybe we could just
skip that whole rigmarole and leave it
at the fact that I care about this issue
for the same reason that I care about
anything else because I'm a human being
with a brain and my brain forms ideas
okay and I share those ideas that's it
that's the whole reason do you need more
it's just the most annoying response
someone is sharing their opinion about
anything and you what do you care about
this because I do I just because because
I'm a person and I have an opinion here
it is the other response to it
sure I know I could give you more
reasons why I care I'm see I'm all about
letting people live their lives okay the
problem is that that's the exact
opposite of what the LGBTQ camp does
especially the T in the LGBTQ camp okay
they're the last ones that are
interested in letting people live their
lives I mean let people live are you
kidding me
they are literally trying to control the
language that we use not just in their
presence but in general they're trying
to force us to not only accept but
affirm and promote anti-scientific
nonsense they want us all to deny
science 2/2 out biology to deny common
sense and I say no and your response is
why do I care okay how about this Robbie
I demand okay I demand right it doesn't
matter why I demand it none your
business I demand that you affirm that
two plus two equals five and I want you
to say that not just to me not just when
you're around me but anywhere for the
rest of your life I demand that you
pretend that two plus two equals five
what you won't you won't do that right
why do you care so much you freak you
weirdo why do you care I mean it's just
two plus two equals five it's just
arithmetic what do you what do you care
doesn't affect you now you say that it
doesn't hurt you if somebody wants to
live as a woman well good for you
just tells me though that you aren't a
teenage girl with a boy verging into
your locker room or on to your track
team and stealing all of your medals and
your achievements that kind of hurts
them III think don't you think being
deprived of privacy being deprived of
the achievements that you've worked for
I don't know that seems like that might
hurt
now you're right that particular part of
it doesn't hurt me because I'm not a
teenage girl either although according
to the left I could be if I want it to
be but here's the thing so it doesn't
affect me but I actually care about
people who aren't me can you imagine
that it's only caring about the stuff
that affects you personally do you know
what that's called it's called
narcissism this is one of the problems I
have with libertarianism with with the
attitude of it doesn't affect you you
shouldn't care okay that's that's just
very thinly veiled narcissism where
you're claiming that only the things
that directly affect you should you care
about it also doesn't really affect me
that people are starving in Ethiopia
should does that mean I shouldn't care
about it so basically your charge
against me is that I'm not a narcissist
guilty as charged you got me now here's
the thing if a guy wants to go around
claiming that he's a woman fine she
wants to claim that he's Cleopatra fine
he could say is the Queen of England I
don't care but if he demands that I
affirm it now we have a problem if he
tries to change the English language to
support his delusion now we have a
problem if he tries to change school
curriculum to indoctrinate kids into his
fantasy now we have a problem if he in
any way tries to impose his falsehood on
anyone doesn't have to be me but any
other person now we have a problem and
I'm
have something to say about it and so
should you
okay but I really appreciate the email
and thank you for listening and we will
leave it there thank somebody for
watching thanks for being a part of
another show I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]